joining us now a CBS News political
director Steve shigera Steve good
morning morning strangely this might
qualify as a quiet week at the White
House but what are we make of this calm
this cryptic calm before him the storm
comment as they narrow called it the
presidential riddle yeah I think it's
the latest episode of what does Donald
Trump really mean when he says something
right I mean we've played this game
since he became a presidential candidate
he says something we then try to ascribe
a motive for to try to figure out what
he's talking about I think the thing
that has people a little bit unnerved
about this is he did this standing in
front of a bunch of military leader ISM
and it led to a lot of people asking the
question does he you know with the
tensions between Iran and the United
States with North Korea does he mean
something more than just throwing a line
out there like he's done in the past no
one really knows we've asked a lot of
questions they haven't answered so we're
trying to figure this one out
well and in the Department of the
inscrutable what happens now between the
State Department and the White House
specifically as it concerns Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson he called the
president a name we are reportedly we
know the president is no fan of
personal insults when they are directed
towards him well but the president and
the president's spokesperson says that
he still has confidence and Rex
Tillerson I think you know this is a
frayed relationship we've seen that play
out publicly but it doesn't seem like
there's much of a desire to tell
Tillerson to go at this point there's
been enough shake ups going on at this
White House I think losing another
cabinet member especially in light of
what happened with the Health and Human
Services Secretary in his in his private
jet given the issues we've gotten out
with North Korea with it with Iran I
mean how how much how much longer can a
relationship that is as as frayed as
this one is can kind of continue given
that you know what's at stake here
I mean that's a very good question I
think the the issue here is is how much
is people listening to the president and
how much are people listening to the
president's advisors and if the sense is
that Tillerson and defense secretary
mattis and chief of staff John Kelly
have a lot to say in this operation and
they can continue to run what they're
doing parallel to what the president's
doing then maybe it can it can run for a
while I think the sense is there's those
folks and there's been some reporting
that those folks are sticking together
to work
with this president to make sure they
keep him on the right track and so it's
it's a bigger issue for those guys as
opposed to just turning their backs and
walking and there is a lot on the
horizon Steve I mean the president is
reportedly going to decertify the Iran
nuclear deal what are the implications
of that gets kicked to Congress two
weeks what do we expect to happen well
that's another question because the
president's talk tough on the campaign
and since about the Iran deal calling it
the worst deal ever and calling it an
embarrassment when he went to the UN but
there's not necessarily a slam-dunk
situation in Congress to kill this thing
right Republicans have talked tough but
then you look at what especially in the
Senate there's only a two-seat majority
in the Senate and there's some
Republican senators they wait a minute
let's step back here let's look at this
are we ready to pull the plug on this
yet you have pressure from from foreign
governments governments especially
Europeans were involved in this deal
saying don't pull out of this and so it
might not be the slam-dunk it might be
him punting to Congress let them deal
with so you what I was gonna say what's
his motive then and kicking it back to
Congress well he can say that he
decertified and you can tell his
supporters hey look you know what I'm
still calling this deal terrible but
it's up to Congress to fix this and
we've seen what happens when the
president leaves it to Congress to fix
things haven't really been fixed right
Obamacare is a classic well on and on
that note of Obamacare the president is
making good on a promise he made to
religious leaders he is narrowing the
contraception coverage mandate there is
gonna be a lot of hue and cry potential
lawsuits why spoil for an ideological
fight right now well first of all keep
in mind this is the religious
conservatives evangelicals this is one
of those unequivocal supporters of this
president and so this is a little reward
to them to say look you know what I
thank you for your all your support
throughout the campaign and through my
presidency at a point when he's not the
most popular person in the country so
there's that but it's also interesting
you look at the birth control part of
this and they framed some of this in the
deregulation push which this president
has really been going since the
beginning of his presidency
rolling back Obama era regulations I
think that's gonna be a big legal
argument for them if this goes to the
courts lot of action at the courts Steve
shigera it's always good to see you
thanks for your time thanks welcome back
thank you tomorrow morning on Face the
Nation right here on CBS John
Dickerson's guests will include Wayne
LaPierre executive
as president of the National Rifle
Association and Senator Dianne Feinstein
Democrat of California